FORTHCOMING IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CAN
LIE TO US, BUT IF MICHAEL FLYNN
LIES, THAT IS IT.
>> Brian: MARK STEYN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IN THE HOUSE, A DRAMA OVER THE
INFAMOUS TRUMP DOSSIER, BUT THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAS
SUBPOENAED JOHN McCAIN'S
ASSOCIATE.
SEEKING MORE INFORMATION ON THE
SOURCES BEHIND THE DOSSIER,
KRAMER MET WITH THE DOSSIERS
AUTHOR, CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE
INVESTIGATOR WITH A GREAT
REPUTATION, HAPPENED AT
McCAIN'S WORD QUEST.
AND HANDED OVER TO THE FBI, AT
WHICH TIME THEY SAID, WE GOT
THIS ALREADY, MOLLIE HEMINGWAY
IS A SENIOR EDITOR.
COFOUNDER OF REAL CLEAR
POLITICS, THEY JOIN US.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS DOSSIER,
WHY IS THAT OF INTEREST TO
FIGURE OUT HOW McCAIN GOT IT
AND BY HIS ASSOCIATE GAVE IT TO
HIM?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF INTEREST IN
THE ROLE THAT JOHN McCAIN
WE KNOW THAT THE FBI HAD THE
DOSSIER PRIOR TO THAT AND HANDED
OVER IN INSTALLMENTS AS IT WAS
BEING COLLECTED, THAT'S PRETTY
INTERESTING IF NOT SCANDALOUS
INFORMATION IN ITS SELF.
THIS GUY CAME IN, THE McCAIN
AIDE CAME IN AND WAS NOT WILLING
TO TELL WHO THE SOURCES WERE
COMING HE KNOWS WHO THE SOURCES
WERE IN SOME CASES, BUT NOT
WILLING TO SAY WHO THEY WERE.
THAT IS INTERESTING, IN SOME
CASES WE ALREADY KNOW WHO SOME
OF THE SOURCES WERE AND WHAT IS
THE HARM IN SHARING IT?
WHY IS HE PROTECTING THE
SOURCES?
IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT
AMERICANS HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
KNOW WHO THE SOURCES ARE FOR
EACH AND EVERY UNFOUNDED OR
SALACIOUS ALLEGATION IN THE
BOUNDLESS INVESTIGATION.
AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
I HOPE THAT HE WILL SHARE THAT
INFORMATION AND THAT EVERYBODY
WOULD BE FORTHRIGHT AND HONEST
WHEN THEY ARE TALKING TO
INVESTIGATORS.
>> Brian: DAVID KRAMER WORKS
AT THE INSTITUTE, HE HANDED US
OFF.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS AN
ANALYST BETWEEN McCAIN AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE OF THE
SHOT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
AT HIM AND OTHER THINGS.
HAVING SAID THAT, DAVID KRAMER
REALLY HAS NOTHING TO HIDE.
IF YOU JUST GOT HANDED THE
MYSTERY HERE?
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION, I
AGREE WITH MOLLY, HE SHOULD
TESTIFY, THERE'S NO REASON THAT
HE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO TELL
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE WHO
THOUGH SOURCES WERE, AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO WHO KNOW WHO THE
SOURCES WERE TO MAKE ASSESSMENTS
AND VALUE JUDGMENTS ABOUT THE
VERACITY OF THE INFORMATION,
THAT IS WHAT CRITICS OF THIS
DOSSIER SAY THAT IT IS
UNFOUNDED, ALL OF THESE
TRUE, AND THEY BELIEVE THAT A
LOT OF IT IS, WE NEED TO KNOW
WHERE THEY SOURCES ARE AND WHO
THEY WERE AND WHERE THE
BACK TO THE FEUD BETWEEN
McCAIN AND TRUMP, HE SENT
DAVID KRAMER OVER TO MEET WITH
CHRIS OVER STEEL AFTER THE
ELECTION, MID-TO-LATE NOVEMBER
AND THEN PROCEEDED TO PASS THE
DOSSIER OVER TO JAMES COMEY, SO
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS PRETTY
INTERESTING.
HE WOULD DO THIS AFTER TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
>> Brian: WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND
OUT WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
PREVENTING ALL OF THIS FROM
COMING OVER IN AND SAYING, THE
WORLD AT THE DOSSIER PLATE AND
THE UNMASKING OF SOME LEVEL WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OVERALL
INVESTIGATION, THE FBI PERHAPS
IS ABOUT TO BE EXTREMELY
EMBARRASSED AT THE HIGH LEVEL
WITH THIS INVESTIGATION, MAYBE
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND THAT OUT AS
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND THAT OUT AM
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND THAT OUT AN
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND THAT OUT AY
HAD FOR THE EXITS INCLUDING
OF JUSTICE TO ANSWER CONGRESS'
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DOSSIER AND
ITS USE IN SECURING A WIRETAP
AGAINST THEIR TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AFFILIATE.
THEY HAVE BEEN REALLY, REALLY
NOT FORTHRIGHT ABOUT THEIR ROLE.
AND THAT IT'S CAUSING A LOT OF
PROBLEMS FOR INVESTIGATORS,
DEVIN NUNES, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE SENT A
LETTER TO ROD ROSENSTEIN SAYING
THAT ALL OF THE INFORMATION
NEEDS TO BE TURNED OVER BY
JANUARY 3RD, THEY PREVIOUSLY
CLAIMED THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE
DOCUMENTS THAT THEY DO HAVE.
ALL OF THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE ARE GROWING TIRED OF THAT
SEEING.
>> Brian: TONK, VERY QUICK, 35
PAGES LONG, CULTIVATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE HOST OF
"THE APPRENTICE FOR TEN YEARS AT
THE REQUEST OF VLADIMIR PUTIN,
THEY WANTED TO CONTROL THE
COUNTRY, IT SOUNDS
PLAUSIBLE.
>> SOME OF THE ALLEGATIONS IN
THE DOSSIER ARE JUST COMING YOU
KNOW, SO WILD AND BEYOND BELIEF.
BUT TO THE OVERALL POINT, RIGHT,
THIS DOCUMENT IS THE ONE THAT
SPUN THE ENTIRE INVESTIGATION.
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN
RUSSIA, NOT RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
IN THE ELECTION, BUT COLLUSION,
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING TO